You know what this is?
It's a tomato
First,
It was a seed
You take care of a garden,
It takes care of that
You feed it,
It feeds you
Few things in this world operate like that
Fair and square
Just needs a place to grow
Grow,
And grow,
Then it comes out
And it's part of the world
Because you know what the dream really is?
It's life
Life is the dream
The only dream
I've got a question,
Why are we out here, just what are we doing in the middle of the goddamn desert tonight?
That's right, that's right. You want that music only Jimmy can make?
Let me tell you something about Jimmy
You know why Jimmy's here?
He's bad batch
Not a functioning member of society, that's what they told him
That's right
All of us here,
We weren't good enough,
Smart enough,
Young enough,
Healthy enough,
Wealthy enough,
Sane enough
Freaks
Parasites
This here is the bad batch
We ain't good, we're bad
The only things you've done,
Have put you right here
With me
It's life
Life is the dream
The only dream
Costs a lot to be here. Costs you an arm and a leg